Das ist wirklich eine absolute sensation es gibt sauberes wasser auf dem mars
Das ist was ergibt das war ja schon lange klar in welchen mengen und ob es nutzbar sein würde
Das war alles andere als gewiss jetzt gibt es aber neue kenntnisse und die sind wirklich sensationell der mars reconnaissance orbiter
Hat sogar massive vorkommen entdeckt wie genau und vor allem die frage aller fragen wie ist die lage
Auf dem mars und was bedeutet das für zukünftige mars-mission jetzt den klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Erst einmal vielen dank an uwe schmidt der uns heute morgen den link per mail geschickt
Hat ja das sind meldungen die das herz. Höher schlagen lassen der mars reconnaissance orbiter
hat tatsächlich
Massive eisschichten unter dem marsboden entdeckte wasser das ist ja schon länger durch zahlreiche beweisen belegt gibt es in form von eis auf
dem roten planeten
2008 gab es die ersten fotos als der nasa phoenix maß länder am 15 juni dem
21 tag seiner mission mit seiner schaufel
eisfrei legte eine absolute sensation zum ersten mal war damit klar und sichtbar es gibt wasser auf
Dem mars in eis vom war ein absoluter
gänsehautmoment zahlreiche weitere erkenntnisse wurden inzwischen gewonnen aber zum beispiel die entdeckung von flüssigem wasser
Wurde im nachhinein in frage gestellt
Im video kein leben auf dem mars möglich hatten wir darüber berichtet aber bis heute blieben zahlreiche
Fragen offen wie viel wasser gibt es ist es sauber genug kann es genutzt werden denn das ist eine der absolut wichtigen fragen kann eine
Zukünftige mars-mission das eis auf dem mars nutzen um wasser daraus zu gewinnen
Mit der aktuellen entdeckung ist die nasa der beantwortung dieser fragen nähergekommen der mars reconnaissance orbiter
Fand das eis an steilhängen die durchmaß winde freigelegt worden waren und so kein staub die schichten bedeckte dadurch
Konnte er mit seiner high rise kamera der high resolution imaging science experiment
kamera aufnahmen machen die
Beeindruckendes zeigen zum einen scheint das eis sehr klar zu sein man könnte wahrscheinlich eben rein ins wasser daraus gewinnen dann ist die schicht mit
Knapp 130 metern sehr dick und diese schichten die können jetzt die klimageschichte
des mars sehr gut
Nachvollziehbar machen so kann mit einer mission zu diesen stellen in zukunft auch erkundet werden ob das leben auf dem mars gab oder hätte geben
können oder sogar noch gibt zitat unter etwa einem drittel der marsoberfläche
befindet sich
Oberflächennahes eis das die jüngste geschichte. Des mars aufgezeichnet hat so der hauptautor der studie können dann das vom astrobiologie
Science center des us geological survey
Und eines ist jetzt für die von der europäischen, weltraumagentur esa
geplanten exomars mission eine wirklich
Unglaubliche erkenntnis jetzt ist zum ersten mal bekannt in welcher tiefe sich das eis befindet und das ist der absolute wahnsinn
Ein bis zwei meter und genau in diese tiefe soll die exomars mission zum ersten mal sie wird damit ein
wichtiger meilenstein für eine bemannte mars-mission denn dann kann wirklich geklärt werden ob aus diesem
Eiswasser gewonnen werden kann das ist wirklich ein riesiger schritt für die raumfahrt da kriege. Ich echt gänsehaut der absolute wahnsinn
unfasslich ich bin
So gespannt was sich jetzt noch alles aus dieser entdeckung ergibt denn sie bedeutet ja auch das eine mission auch komplett ohne
bohrung auskommt und an diesen hängen bis zu
130 meter in die tiefe in den marsboden blicken kann
Hammer wenn ihr keine nachricht vom mars verpassen wollt dann wird mir. Ja kein aber aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke der nur dann verpasst er kein video hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
Außerirdisches leben auf dem mars neue indizien ja ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran